Donald Trump and Rudy Giuliani are just at the
beginning of their legal troubles, you heard a
couple of weeks ago that Rudy Giuliani is under
serious legal pressure for his false claims about
Dominican voting machines and their alleged
role in the 2012 presidential election.
Now, Donald Trump and Rudy Giuliani are being
sued for their role in inciting the January 6th
riots. And it's not just one lawsuit. There is
going to be, in theory, lots of legal money to
be made by lawyers defending these guys over
the next few years if they actually pay their
legal bills. Let's talk about the two lawsuits
that are going on first and foremost. The NAACP
has sued Rudy Giuliani and Donald Trump,
as well as two white supremacist groups,
citing their role in the January 6th insurrection.
In addition to this, Mississippi Democratic
Representative Bennie Thompson, in his personal
capacity, has also sued Donald Trump and Rudy
Giuliani. This lawsuit was filed yesterday morning
in federal district court for Washington, D.C.
It says Trump and Rudy, in collaboration with
the proud Boys and Oath Keepers, conspired to
incite the riot to keep Congress from certifying
the results of the 2020 presidential election.
And it says that they're doing so specifically
violated the Klu Klux Klan I'm sorry,
the Ku Klux Klan Act, which is a statute
designed to protect both formerly enslaved
black Americans as well as lawmakers in Congress
from white supremacist violence. Representatives
Hank Johnson and Bonnie Watson Coleman are going
to be joining the litigation as plaintiffs in the
coming days. And the lawsuit really spells out not
just, you know, one of the one of the I don't know
about interesting, but one of the notable aspects
of the case made against Donald Trump by the House
impeachment managers in Trump's second impeachment
trial, which concluded on Saturday, of course,
with Donald Trump's acquittal. Was that the
focus, understandably, because Trump was the one
being tried, was on things Donald Trump said
and did. But when you step back from that a
little bit and you see the bigger picture, which
includes Rudy Giuliani, it includes Jouni Giuliani
and Janet Ellis flying around the country holding
these bogus voter fraud hearings, which were not
nobody was even under oath. They were not formal
hearings in any in any real sense of the word.
That's a bigger part of the entire thing. And,
of course, Rudy Giuliani talking about trial
by combat on January six. Certainly a big part
of what what we are expecting to see as part of
this lawsuit. And this is admittedly a statute,
the Ku Klux Klan, Ku Klux Klan Act, that this is
this is not frequently used or cited, but it does
at least superficially appear to be relevant here.
And it specifically is for bringing civil actions.
These are lawsuits. These are not criminal
charges. Now, separately, as you know, Donald
Trump is under criminal investigation in the state
of Georgia for that phone call he made to Georgia.
Republican officials asking them to find eleven
thousand seven hundred and eighty votes, I believe
is the exact number, the number he needed to
win the state of Georgia instead of Joe Biden. We
know of possible criminal investigations happening
in New York. So this is likely going to go
on for some time now. As far as the lawsuit
for Trump and Rudy's inciting of the riots, there
is a real question there about a possible class
action for collective trauma. I had a class
action attorney emailed me yesterday saying
it would be really difficult. Who exactly has
standing to be party to that class action? I mean,
there's certainly some some questions there, but
that is that is an interesting legal question.
There are going to be legal problems for Donald
Trump and people around him for a very long time.
And there is no doubt that for some period,
Trump and and even the Republican Party
is widely speaking, going to dodge
accountability in all ways in 2022.
We will see for the first time electorally
whether some of these people that came to power
on the coattails of Trump. I'm, of course, talking
about the I don't know what to call them exactly,
but Madison Cawthorn, Marjorie Taylor Green and
Lauren Bobert, we are if they got reelected, that
would be a big sign that this Trumpy and Wing is
not going to suffer any consequences for what they
did in 2020. And we know that much of the American
public has a short memory and that they may have
moved on to who knows what will be going on in.
Twenty two, as far as Trump is concerned,
Trump's legal problems aren't going away, even if
this specific lawsuit isn't going to be more than
a small thorn in his side, there may be one
hundred thorns, could be a sort of death of
a thousand paper cuts sort of situation.
And certainly Donald Trump is going to be
racking up significant legal bills. Whether he
will pay them, as always, remains to be seen.